now it is my pleasure to introduce
Michael epic so Mike is a professor of
civil environmental engineering at
Stanford and is also a senior fellow at
Stanford Woods Institute for the
environment he has several appointments
across the Stanford campus which are too
long to go through right now but most
importantly he is also the faculty
director of Stanford online's product
management program so we're so happy to
have Mike here with us to lead this
conversation with Ashley about his
career trajectory from product
management to venture capital and now
I'll hand things off to Mike
hey Liz thank thanks thanks so much
great job on my bio saying my
appointments across campus are too many
to mention that's very helpful
um so uh I'm really excited today to uh
to to be uh welcoming ashmeet um to this
discussion around sort of the future uh
of of people who want to go into product
management and and how he has
experienced his career building off of
his product management experience so so
before we get into the discussion a
little bit uh about about Ash me he's
the founder and chief engineer of
engineering capital and if you don't
know what that is check it out it's an
it's an amazing organization it invests
before traditional Venture firms and
specializes in leading seed rounds in
software companies with technical
insight
experience includes running Venture
Capital funds and Leadership positions
helping build the industry-leading
products vmware's ESX server and silicon
Graphics web Force
so ashmeet started his career at
Hewlett-Packard and silicon Graphics as
an engineer
for the purposes of this webinar it's
most important to know that he then went
to VMware where he ran product
management for their Flagship product
the SX server
now following his product management
role he transitioned into Venture
Capital where he was a general partner
at Foundation capital a leading Silicon
Valley venture capital firm with about
2.4 billion under management
his successful Investments include Azure
and Signal FX acquired by Splunk for a
billion dollars
to be TV
um and a variety of others he currently
serves on the board of directors of
convinced cognitos and nexla his
additional active Investments include as
Millie kentick Menlo security robust
intelligence V function and Yoda scale
in all of which he was the seed investor
ashmit received an MBA from Wharton with
honors and Ms in computer science from
Stanford University and a BS in computer
science summa [ __ ] laude from USC and
interestingly in his spare time he can
also be found planning his second trip
to Mount Everest so Ashby thanks so much
for joining us today
um and it's a pleasure to to have this
discussion with you
thank you Mike it's always fun to be
back on the Stanford campus virtually in
this case
well it's it's always fun to have you
here in person as well so uh I guess my
first question is can you give us a
little bit more information about your
product management role at VMware and
your responsibilities with regard to the
overall project management team a
product management team and specifically
with regard to ESX server
so VMware was organized in a classical
Silicon Valley Product LED organization
where we had functional groups running
product management marketing sales and
Engineering I headed the product
management function for ESX server which
eventually became the flagship product
for VMware when I joined VMware this is
right after the throws of the.com Crash
I had actually just come back from Mount
Everest from my first trip after having
burnt some energy after having sold the
company
and wanted to get back to work and join
VMware when it was a small startup
organization nobody had heard of us we
had you know a handful of millions in
revenues and ESX server was essentially
an r d project that was a technology
sitting on the shelf
um which you know we had conviction the
company had conviction would be an
important product but had not yet found
product Market fit I was tasked with
building that organization finding
product Market fit and running the
entire product management function the
official title was director of product
management for ESX server eventually we
became over 90 of the revenue of the
company so essentially you can think of
VMware and ESX are synonymous in terms
of the eventual evolution of what the
company became
yeah well that that's amazing that you
you go from and what was what was
functionally in an r d an r d project
that yes was on the Shelf but but wasn't
really a commercialized or or or or or
or or
um uh you know a widely available
product can can you talk a little bit
about about launch right and and I'm
sure at some point in there there was a
pretty interesting product launch and we
actually had some interesting
discussions yesterday about about
product launch and and how how we know
like when as a product ready to actually
go so you said it was kind of off the
shelf but but there wasn't good product
Market fit and and can you talk a little
bit how how you guided the the the
product team
um from sort of yes this this Mason
product which looked very interesting
but then to actually launching and going
out
yeah so I think there's two there's two
uh questions embedded in the way you ask
that Mike and I'd like to share a quick
anecdote on the first one on the first
way I'm looking at it which is the
actual physical launch of the product
um and I of course this is a small
startup at this point and I distinctly
remember standing over there on first of
July 2003
um when we launched ESX 2 and um uh you
know speaking to a handful of people in
the room which is the entire worldwide
you know
that was everybody at that point the
company at that point and standing over
there and saying we're launching esx2
blah blah blah this is the positioning
Etc and I'll get into some of those
details and saying one day there will be
one million virtual machines in the
world and people actually laughed
um hip-hop here he is you know Ashley
you know smoking something interesting
again uh things because we literally had
you know no one using it right I mean
forward 15 years and today we have not
Millions but billions of virtual
machines now running in the world now
they are not all ESX virtual machines
um obviously Amazon became a very
important uh product in that space
Amazon AWS and literally billions of
machines run over there but I would
Hazard a guess that today the entire
Cloud ecosystem this on24 platform that
we are running on
um you know everybody who uses all the
software on a daily basis it all runs in
a virtual machine and so I'm extremely
proud of the fact that you know we took
that position and we were able to do
that so in terms of launch it is an act
of belief there has to be someone in
this case it was me and a handful of
other people at VMware who believed that
virtual machines was a very powerful way
to run software and the right way to run
software in the long term and that
proved to be correct
go ahead I was just going to clarify
that in terms of finding product Market
fit you know that's a completely
different process that is the that is
one of the key jobs of a product manager
um you know the product manager is
tasked with taking all these discrete
resources engineering Marketing sales
technology studying the market and
coming up with what I call the answer
the product and finding product Market
fit this includes you know for the
product this includes what is the
packaging what is the pricing how are
you going to promote it how are you
going to position it all of the PS
um in the modern sense of of a product
really should be defined by a good
product manager and I hasten to add that
there are companies where product
management is sometimes glorified
project management that's a different
task project managers are also important
and especially in larger companies they
can be very valuable but product
management is really the CEO of the
product it's the person who takes all
those disparate resources and comes up
with the strategy and the solution on
what would be a for corner well and I
think that's a I think that's a really
important fabulous distinction to say
look as a product manager if you don't
have some of the autonomy and authority
to to make some of those decisions uh
then then it's something that needs to
be looked at in a deeper way with regard
to your roles and responsibilities
because uh yes you should be the de
facto uh CEO of your product and your p
l because that is a really important set
of resources that a product manager
needs to have unlike a project manager
which is which is functionally trying to
manage various resources across the
Matrix of a of a cross-functional
organization
right a project manager is a
coordination function a product manager
is a strategy function it's a it's a
function about how are you going to
allocate resources to make those
critical decisions and you know the good
decisions and strategy come out of a lot
of hard work there's a lot of repetitive
repeated learnings trial and error
iteration that you have to do perhaps no
different than you may do in a lab when
you are doing research or no different
than in sales when you're doing sales
but in product management it's about
bringing all of them together so for
example in the specific case of ESX
server you know we never sold it as an
operating system of course it was an
operating system we never sold it as a
hardware virtualization of course we
were doing hardware virtualization we
sold it as a server consolidation
solution and I distinctly remember the
day I knew that was the answer so one of
the good habits that every product
manager should practice is talking to
customers you've got to talk to
customers on a regular basis and you
have to understand the customer better
than the customer understands themselves
um and I was on the phone with the
customer at Bank of America who had
purchased a copy of ESX server and I
asked him so you know why did you buy it
and he was like well you know Rob is a
friend of mine and he's the sales guy
and he said I should try it and I was
like oh man that's a terrible reason
it's like you know it's like your your
body sold it to you yeah how many
friends does Rob have because you're
gonna need a lot of them exactly hacking
exactly and so here's a here's a phone
call going downhill uh but then I said
so what are you doing with it and he
said oh you know Windows Microsoft has
and I'm going to just put all my windows
NTS on them and immediately my ears
worked out and I could literally feel
the hair standing on the back of my neck
because there is a lot of Windows NT in
the end of life in 2003 you know
Microsoft had announced Windows 2003
they wanted to get rid of all the old
versions and I was like aha
here's a use case here's a value
proposition that can be replicated
That's Unique that we would have an
unfair advantage on which will have a
very quick Roi a very quick return on
investment and so you know based on that
we were able to find product Market fit
and server consolidation took us from
zero to a billion dollars you know the
first billion dollars in revenues was
really made on the backs of server
consolidation at VMware so that's that's
an amazing story of how customers can
teach you so much provided that you
listen
and and how important that is
uh I could not repeat that more often
Mike you have said the magic words you
know it really is about listening and
it's about listening without having
happy years all of us especially product
managers are optimists we are looking to
the future we want things to happen and
so we suffer from what my mentor
Catherine used to call happy years in
other words we listen to the part of the
conversation that confirms what we are
seeing confirmation bias
um and we've ignore the other data
points in terms of what they're saying
so product managers really have to be
have to be able to listen objectively it
is an essential skill for a product
manager to practice and like any good
skill it can be learned by iteration and
practice
um and uh and it really can change your
career if you listen very carefully and
objectively to what the customers are
saying the truth is not in the room the
truth is not
um is not known to the product manager
the truth is in the customer's head the
truth is over there but customers will
not use the words that we want to use so
you have to listen carefully and you
have to tease it out of them you have to
figure out what is it that they're
really saying
absolutely all right well I want to
switch gears a little bit to um to the
focus of this uh of this of this webinar
so so from product management at VMware
you transition to venture capital
can you share with us a little bit about
that experience and and and then also
you know what did you what do you think
do you think there were specific things
that you did as a product manager that
you learned as a product manager that
you practiced as a product manager that
made you the successful Venture
capitalists that you became and are
today
yes I was very fortunate
um to have worked with the product
manager because I do believe that
product management is an excellent
training to be a venture capitalist it
is also excellent training to be a CEO
to be an entrepreneur so there are many
functions that come out of being a
product manager because it is one of
those rare jobs in a company where you
have to look at the entire package and
then break it down into the individual
pieces and come up with a coherent
answer most importantly a product
manager has to know how to say no they
have to say no do a whole bunch of stuff
and prioritize what is it that you can
do you always have limited resources you
always have limited time you always have
competitive threats all of these forces
are working against you and the only
solution to all of them is
prioritization it is being able to take
the signal away from the noise and so
that's what you learn to do as a product
manager and yes that was very helpful to
me in terms of making a transition to
venture capital the way it actually
happened in my particular case was
accidental so VMware was sold relatively
early in the Journey of the company we
were sold I believe 2003 or 2004 in any
case in 2005 I was leaving VMware I
decided that I wanted to start another
company and actually started spending
time with some Venture capitalists with
the intention of raising money
um including the good Folks at
Foundation capital and it was my chew
and Catherine two of the senior Partners
there Catherine was one of the founders
who literally said to me one day and
said hey you know we'd love to fund with
you as an as in your company and all of
these new ideas that you're talking
about but have you ever thought of being
a venture capitalist so uh it was
literally at the Christmas party and so
I was like hmm that's an interesting
question why do you ask
uh you know one thing led to another and
they said you know you should spend some
time with us uh you know in a venture
partner sort of as a temporary partner
type of role let's get to know each
other better and then I feel like you
will will bring you in as a real partner
and so I was there as a general partner
then as a managing partner for the last
three years you know managing a large
firm
um and they trained me you know I
learned Venture Capital thanks to Mike
shoe Catherine Google Elmore sort of the
founders of the firm and I do believe
that the product management skills of
prioritization of you know listening to
conflicting data there's no such thing
as a perfect investment anytime you
diligence and investment as a venture
capitalist you're going to get
conflicting data you have to then make
the Judgment of which data to prioritize
which investment to prioritize how to
deal with it just like a product manager
does there's always happy customers and
unhappy customers customers who created
value customers who haven't received
value your job as a product manager is
to figure out where is the signal in
that noise
well you know I guess two two points on
that one one of the things that of
course you know well is we always talk
with aspiring or practicing Venture
capitalists or Angel Investors about the
importance of a thesis and having
conviction and saying look this is what
I think the future is going to look like
and and therefore these are the types of
firms that I am going to invest in and
you know talking back about your your
launch anecdote with um with with ESX
server you had a conviction as a product
manager that yes someday
so many of these machines were going to
be virtual in nature and and in some
regards it's the formation of that type
of conviction that type of idea that is
analogous to the formation of an
investment thesis yeah an investment
thesis is a little bit broader but it
requires you to look at to look at an
industry sector to to think about trends
that are happening and what it's going
to take to make that future how happen
which which which is such a big part of
of venture capital investing
yeah so um the way I like to describe
the opinions that a product manager or a
venture capitalist should have is strong
opinions lightly held
um you need to have strong opinions in
other words you've got to have Clarity
of vision you've got they've got to be
strong they've got to be based on facts
they've got to be something where you
have done the hard work to identify uh
you know why you have that opinion but
they have to be likely held because the
world is changing very quickly if
anything it's getting faster it's not
getting slower you have to be able to
react to the world moving around you and
um you know both as a product manager
and as a venture capitalist speed is an
enormous competitive advantage and the
particular product management story that
I like to give people is to talk about
product Market fit in the context of
Facebook so Facebook everybody's
familiar with is a fabulous company they
were Venture funded they did a great job
they found product Market fit and they
were growing very very quickly news feed
was working advertising was working
um lots of users were coming in
engagement was going up and they were
printing money
and then one day Cambridge analytica
happens in the UK there is a privacy
Scandal information comes out in how
information is being shared Etc nothing
that was done by Facebook themselves on
that particular day or week or month it
had the actual actions had taken years
and had taken place years in the past
and in one instant product Market fit
changed for facebook facebook went from
having perfect product Market fit to
having a declining product Market fit
and it continues to decline to this day
to the point that um you know I would be
so bold as to say that they don't have
product Market fit and now Mark
Zuckerberg has given up on the core
product of Facebook and the future of
Facebook or meta is really about the
metaverse and WhatsApp in other words
instant messaging and uh you know 3D
vrar Etc
um nothing to do with the original where
product Market fit was so perfect in the
original news feed so it changes so you
can have a strong opinion you can be
working firing on all cylinders and then
in an incident the world changes around
yeah I know it's it's a it's absolutely
true and I do like that idea strong
opinions lightly held the the other
thing that that I think from a a venture
capital standpoint is we always talk
about the idea of smart money
meaning that it's not just a check for
an entrepreneur it's that you want yes
money is great but but you want support
you want confidants that will give your
company great advice and just as
importantly you want people on your
board of directors normally an
Institutional Investor if that's the
case that can provide more value than
just simply writing that check and in
your experience as a product manager I
can see that you were incredibly
valuable to product focused startups
that were in a phase of needing to get
prepared for launch and and sort of
manage that product introduction and
growth and scaling because you had done
it at VMware and and and you can provide
at least some really good guidance on
what that process looks like much more
so than potentially another investor
that doesn't have that experience
Mike you're very kind to recognize that
I may be able to add value from my
product management skills and of course
I do strive to do that and yes I believe
all good Venture capitalists and strive
to help their companies the unfortunate
reality is that on average I believe
Venture capitalists are a net negative
so perhaps I'm too cynical
point out to point out that you are
calling the kettle black something
I'm I'm grateful to be recognized that
way
um but you know because Venture
capitalists give money and money of
course is you know very attractive to
most people
um you know people tend there's a halo
effect around Venture Capital now I
believe the great Venture capitalists
can add tremendous value uh and I'm very
proud of you know a couple of instances
where I have been able to add value to
my portfolio companies that the CEOs
have then subsequently recognized
um and you know there's some quotes on
my website and things like that uh in
terms of you know where really there was
an inflection point that I was able to
you know impact but those are rare and
you have to be careful and thoughtful as
a venture capitalist in terms of
overlying your operating background onto
the position of the company the rule of
thumb that I like to give and you know
I've hired many people
um and trained them as Venture
capitalists you know several GPS now at
Foundation Capital were hired by me and
to some extent mentored and trained by
me
um the the rule of thumb that I like to
tell Venture Capital new Venture
capitalists people who are transitioning
from let's say a product management role
or perhaps you know some other
leadership role in an organization is
you will probably have great ideas
10 times an hour when you're sitting in
a in your first few board meetings
on average
you should think that you will share
that idea once a year
that's the numbers of orders of
magnitude of how much you have to
recalibrate yourself in other words you
will think of a great suggestion a great
input a great idea and you mean it with
the best of intentions you know here's
the CEO he's running hard she's running
hard she's got ideas and you're like why
don't you do this why don't you do that
you should do this better you should not
do this you should spend it there and
you will get 10 ideas an hour and you
get one chance a year to share an idea
so keep your mouth shut and listen uh
and prioritize because you're only going
to get one one bullet a year and that's
the calibration that I think really
helps people understand how much you
have to attenuate your operating
experience before you really start
applying it nobody knows the position as
well as the CEO of a company she is the
one who has as perfect a knowledge as
you can get in the fog of war that she
is fighting as the leader of the company
you have having perfect information
vastly imperfect information and so you
have to be very careful in terms of how
you give advice over there and that's
one of the traps and that's one of the
reasons why VCS end up with bad
reputations uh on board on boards you
know just trying to give advice which is
just not well received for the right
reasons right well and and and you know
recognize a failure to recognize that
your your responsibility is one of
fiduciary responsibility and of course
to provide Good Counsel and Leadership
but not to run the company absolutely
uh so well said Mike you are not running
the company if you're running the
company you have made two mistakes
number one you firstly you pick the
wrong CEO
that is true you shouldn't have made
that investment number two you don't
know your you don't know what your job
is as a VC so uh you should definitely
not be running the company you have many
roles as a venture capitalist in a
company certainly one of them is to give
advice
certainly one of them is a fiduciary of
your Investments that you have made and
you are you know representing as a as a
general partner thirdly you are often a
representative of all the other
shareholders so you're bringing that
fourthly sometimes you're just there for
PR value you know you're there because
your name is going to be leveraged in a
press release on a website in a
recruiting function etc for the you are
there as a recruiter your job is to help
the CEO recruit great people bring them
onto the team help them bring them to
customers fourthly you're there as a
Rolodex you're there to provide contacts
so you have many roles that you can play
as a venture capitalist that are
additive to a CEO but you are not there
to run the company if you're running the
company you have already made two
mistakes sure sure all right so one of
the questions that came in
um was uh you know prioritization and
resource allocation takes a lot of time
and effort but the market does indeed
change quickly and and what would be
your advice on how to balance the effort
in prioritizing and making sure that yes
you do have a workflow you are making
progress versus being agile and
responding to changes in the market but
recognizing that every single change in
prioritization requires time it consumes
limited resources and you can't just
simply be reactionary in nature all the
time
yes so this is a great example of where
you need good judgment
good judgment involves making these
types of trade-offs and it is an art it
comes from experience and iteration we
have to understand that as product
managers as Venture capitalists you have
extremely limited resources Microsoft
will always have more Engineers than
your startup will have Google will
always have more distribution than your
startup will ever have yet we are in
some ways competing cooperating
participating in an ecosystem with them
and so you do have to prioritize and
work against them so let me make a
couple of give a little bit of
background and then come to this
decision you can learn a lot by watching
great product managers prioritize and
one of the best examples of that is
Steve Jobs so Steve Jobs is in my
opinion one of the greatest product
managers that we ever had and go and
watch the launch video of the iPhone
2007 Steve Jobs launches the iPhone and
what is his launch video it's about half
an hour long and what does he say he
says you can listen to music you can
browse the internet and you can make
phone calls
you can listen to music you can browse
the internet you can make phone calls
you can listen to music you can pause
the internet and you can make phone
calls and he repeats that again and
again and again in his launch video that
is where the reason
um he was able to do that is because he
had said no to every other possible
feature that could have been added to
the iPhone all of which were
subsequently added the iPhone eventually
became a platform remember the original
product did not the original iPhone did
not have an app store you could not add
new applications to it and in fact Steve
resisted the idea of an app store for a
while
so uh the idea is to prioritize to
eliminate and pick the things that
matter Steve obviously picked the right
three things to build the iPhone to the
point that very smart people
when they heard what he had done thought
he had made a great mistake in fact if
you want to watch a great video go
online on YouTube you can search for
Steve bomber iPhone launch reaction
because he happened to be on stage when
the iPhone was launched not on the
iPhone screen in a different place and
he was actually recorded so we have
video proof of Steve hearing for the
first time Steve bomber at that time is
the CEO of Microsoft and we have a
recording of Steve reacting to being
told what is in the iPhone obviously you
know Steve Jobs had done a great job of
hyping up the launch and bringing up
marketing so everybody knew he was going
to launch a new product but nobody quite
knew what it was that he was going to
launch and the magic reaction remember
most people forget the number one
selling smartphone in the world launched
operating system smartphone in the world
in 2007 was the Windows phone
um Windows operating system was the
number one smartphone operating system
um in the world when the iPhone was
launched and Steve baumer's reaction who
is the CEO of the company that has
obviously uh got this successful product
says
500 dollars there's no
um
exactly exactly and I'm sitting over
here with a 1200 iPhone uh in front of
me
and uh you know obviously Steve bomber
did not understand how much budget was
available for a high high quality user
experience integrated experience to
bring in those two essential
capabilities the music I believe was a
legacy feature I mean that was Steve
George absolutely that was that was just
leveraging iTunes what's clearly
leveraging iTunes and iPod and it was
really about building a phone and a
browser together and doing it in a way
that is just you know fabulous
prioritization the hardest thing to do
is to say no it is not to say yes and so
the bar and what a product manager
really really needs to do is learn how
to say no
um if you really really have to say no
and revisit every time you add a feature
you should say no every time you add a
feature you should say no and here's a
thumb rule that I like to recommend
the best software in the world till
today has never been written by a team
greater than a two Pizza team
in other words a tool that you can feed
with two pizzas and so you really have
to think in terms of you know the iPhone
software the browser was written
literally by two people not to not even
two pizzas you could feed them with half
a pizza
um
and uh you know the greatest software
has been written by very very small
teams and so you have to prioritize
I want to state that again just so that
that it become it becomes clear you
refer to the two Pizza team which is you
know thinking about
um uh the products that you're working
on and developing that that to
streamline and and not have some large
team that continues to add features for
the sake of wow this is really cool is
it what the customer actually needs and
and this and this rule of thumb on a two
Pizza team a team that can be fed by an
order of two pizzas uh I think is a
really unique way to to look at it you
know so what advice would you give to
either aspiring or practicing product
managers with regard to just a couple of
skills that they should be learning or
sharpening while in their role to to
think about that next job whether it's
Venture Capital whether it's moving up
into leadership of a large organization
whatever their goals are and and maybe
if I can say one of them is saying no
that's what I've heard is one of the
lessons here is that that's a skill set
you should learn well uh say no to
things and learn how to say no in in a
way that doesn't close doors that allows
for future add-ons for future features
for future improvements but but but but
allows you to stay focused on what needs
to happen today
yes and the best way of learning how to
say no is to prioritize to think of
everything that you do in life every
organization every email every
conversation every PowerPoint that you
work on it has a prioritization to it
there's a sequence to it and then just
cut off the bottom 80 percent
if you cut it off which is really really
hard to do emotionally you will learn
that you are genuinely prioritizing what
is it that you really want to do I
happen to be someone who loves Adventure
travel who loves to be outside loves
nature I love backpacking and think
about loading your backpack obviously if
you have more food if you have more
equipment it's going to help you in some
situations but guess what it's all going
to go on your back you're gonna have to
physically carry that extra weight and
there's nothing that makes you
prioritize better than knowing that
you're going to be trudging you know
with that load on your back for the next
few days so that's a that's a
visualization that's a way of thinking
about what you do in terms of particular
skills that they should build in
addition to
um you know horizontal skills like being
able to say no or being able to
prioritize a very important vertical
skill that you must must practice is you
have to specialize the world is too bad
asked the knowledge is too much change
is is too much that you must specialize
in something you have to choose that for
yourself what is that specialization in
my case it happens to be computer
science within computer science and
software infrastructure within software
infrastructure it's very early stage
Cloud AI database infrastructure within
that it happens to be investing you know
I don't have a PhD in AI but I have
spent many years thinking about
investing in AI before product Market
fit at that stage and I can you know
talk about where those things are so you
have to specialize which is itself an
act of prioritization in other words you
have to say no to everything else and
then you got to get good at that so
people have to know who you are and what
you should be known for and that is the
way in which you can develop and Advance
yourself
in in an organization in your career
again it's a hard thing to do smart
people
like to do everything they are
interested in everything and so you have
to make those trade-offs in terms of
what you're going to do and if you
specialize well then you will pick an
area and an industry and and a space
that is dynamic that is growing quickly
that is expanding where you will have
more opportunities
you know a good friend of mine who who
runs a a Fortune 100 company
um tells folks that at some point in
their life and in their career they have
to quote monk it up
and and what he means by this is the
difference between being a monk and
being a church priest uh one of them
who's incredibly focused um and and
isn't distracted by the outside world
and everything that comes with say
running a church or running running an
outside organization
um and is only focused on one thing very
very clearly and he says you know
everyone at some point in life has to
either choose to do that or choose to be
a generalist and and the the successful
folks over time have decided at some
point that you have to have that that
monk experience that will always allow
you to go back and say this is my
expertise this is what I do this is my
core and I will build everything off of
this
yes you have to go back and forth I
completely agree you know we want broad
skills um you have to have horizontal
skills and you have to have vertical
skills and both skills are essential for
building you know for for building your
career up and uh building your skills up
um and you tend to go back and forth but
even within them there is an act of
specialization as much as I enjoy nature
as much as I enjoy the outdoors for me
that's a recreational activity I'm never
going to be a world-class mountain
climber I'm never going to win a gold
medal in skiing I'm never going to do
any of those tests
um and I have no Illusions about that so
that's just you know a choice that was
made
um very early in my life
absolutely I would like to point out
that you are a a mountain climber who
has done Everest that is preparing for a
Second Ascent so it's it's not that
you're not good at uh at being outdoors
in nature but you can still be highly um
uh effective uh in in things where you
are not where you're not necessary you
don't necessarily consider your score
your core expertise well human beings
have amazing capacities but I do have to
correct uh one thing in the record I did
not Summit
um so in other words I'm a failed
mountain climber
but uh but you know human beings have
our capacities are vastly more than we
give ourselves credits for and when we
put pressure on ourselves
um is when really the true when when the
truth comes out and that's why you hear
about these exceptional stories about
people at times of war or people in
times of you know stress or accident or
you know people who commit themselves to
startups in these very interesting ways
um we'll do what feel like amazing
things
um but they're really just people who
have pushed themselves to a true limit
who truly push themselves to a limit
no it's it's absolutely true so a couple
of questions that have have come in
um
so you're a product manager
and what's happened you're not well it
had let's let's say it happens that
you're not well aligned with the CEO
um especially in the early stages what
do you do how do you manage conflict
like this and can you be an effective
product manager if if you're not in line
with the CEO and I guess it probably
determines the Summit is determined to
some extent
how big the product is as part of the
you know for the whole company
yeah that's a really difficult problem
to have and there's a few reasons why
you may have so let's first diagnose why
are you not aligned with the CEO one
could one reason and a benign reason
could be because the CEO just doesn't
have the same information that you have
and you just haven't done a good job of
educating the CEO and the rest of the
company on what those opportunities are
and why you believe a certain fact on in
which you are aligned in a different
place if that's the case
that's clearly uh something that
requires communication that can be
solved by communication that is
something that requires you to up your
gain on how you explain and articulate
and and elucidate the opportunity so
that other people can get aligned before
behind you remember most product
managers don't have the authority they
just have the responsibility and so you
have to vote by influence you have to
work indirectly you have to present a
great case study where it is so
glaringly obvious to The Listener what
the right answer is over there now we
also know in the era of fake news and an
approach to third world that sometimes
people will just not listen to facts
sometimes people make up their minds
um regardless of the facts around them
then you have a fatal problem
then you are working in the constraints
of a system where either you have to
decide that there is an alternative path
within the world view of the CEO that is
also a path to success and then you have
to change your mind and work in that
alternative set of facts or you have to
give up and it may well be a fatal
problem and say that it cannot work over
there but that's rare that is really
rare in my experience when I have
mentored product managers and I work
with people most of the time especially
in the B2B Enterprise you know Cloud
infrastructure the spaces that I work in
in the enterprise software I.T space
people are rational actors they want to
make money they want to understand what
customers are doing and if you really
have good customer if you understand the
customer better than anyone else other
people will see it they will be
convinced and they will follow you
that's usually what's required
now I I think your comment that it's
it's in some regards on you as the
product manager to make sure that your
CEO is completely informed of why you
see this as such a big potential is is
spot on all right just in in the last
minute or so a question around
credentialing
um in both
attaining and being successful in a role
like being a VC and then maybe even a
role as a product manager in a technical
organization
how necessary is you know a degree in
say computer science uh like like you
have or or an MBA or or things like this
or do you think you know it it can all
be learned and and I guess this is
partly in the context of the
credentialing that we do in our product
management certificate program
so I am a fan of formal education
whether it's a degree whether it's a
certificate whether it's a program that
you do it is a way of accelerating your
knowledge and speeding up your ability
to go and do something can you learn it
without a credential yes I mean famous
people have you know read books gone
online listen to talks and have been
able to do it but the advantage of a
credential is that some other thoughtful
set of people
prioritized what you need to know
organized it in a fashion that is
logical and hopefully expands and is
easy for you to understand and grow with
and then given you a package deal so a
credential whether it's a degree whether
it's a certificate is a fabulous way of
accelerating your knowledge in a domain
which is why I you know went to school
three times
um you know post-secondary education and
I continue to do a lot of executive
education courses I go to seminars I
listen to uh you know conferences
because it's a way of accelerating your
knowledge are there alternative ways of
doing it can you succeed as a product
manager without a credential yes of
course it's possible
um there are you know it's not there's
nothing that is um so secret or so
hidden that you can only learn it as a
secret craft no but if you want to
accelerate go for it I mean it's one of
the greatest rois that you can have is
to is to educate yourself
well and I think that's that's a great
way to wrap up this webinar
um I want to uh I want to thank you
ashmeet for your your thoughtfulness uh
and and your time today
um I want to encourage everyone if you
haven't already visited it check out
engineering Capital because it's a
fascinating organization that also is
the place where um or Ashby posts a lot
of uh a lot of his thought leadership in
many areas related to this uh and so I'm
gonna turn it back over now after saying
thank you so much to ashmeet to Liz so
she can wrap us up Liz
thank you Mike and thank you Ashley
um an apologies to the audience for not
getting to your questions
um we hope you found this conversation
engaging nonetheless if you are
interested in learning more about
product management you can visit our
website
online.stanford.edu to find more
information about our offerings and
product management and other topics
thanks again everyone